hey uh Donald Trump is now going hard
against the host of MSNBC's Morning Show
once again accusing the co-host Mika
Brzezinski and Joe Scarborough of being
quote neurotic and a mess saying both of
them are total clowns and he's now
threatening to tell the quote real story
about them here's a couple of tweets
that Trump sent out yesterday the first
one is tried watching low-rated Morning
Joe this morning unwatchable morning
Mika meaning Mika Brzezinski is
off-the-wall a neurotic and not very
bright mess he then followed up that
tweet with another one with a threat
someday when things calm down I'll tell
the real story of Joe Scarborough and
his very insecure longtime girlfriend
Mika Brzezinski two clowns why all of a
sudden did Donald Trump start tweeting
threats about media host which by the
way should uniquely disqualify anyone
temperamental II from being President of
the United States apparently he didn't
like this take a look had a great week I
think he's been on message he's shown
maturity as a candidate I think that
he's getting into a groove I think he
likes the new style that he's been out
on the campaign trail producing and and
then
and speaking of so I think he's done
great everything's awesome everything so
this is the part I don't understand if I
think this is it
I mean you just have to look at this as
an opportunity meek is completely right
sarcastically saying oh sure rents
everything is just great with the
campaign obviously the campaign is not
doing great they're losing 22 of the
last 23 recent polls and if that think
Lewis what it says about a presidential
candidate if a host merely saying yeah
you know things aren't really that great
right if that makes it so you take time
from campaigning to tweet threats to
media people you are uniquely
unqualified to be President of the
United States and the threat was totally
empty it's one of those things where
Donald Trump has done this multiple
times I say I know what's really going
on yeah here or I have this information
that I know that nobody else knows and
I'm gonna tell people at some point uh
he doesn't he's got nothing and I hardly
to hear what he knows right when we're
gonna finally get the real story of of
Obama's birth certificate which is a
years in the making now and when we hear
details of his economic plan or Isis
plan or trade plan or plan for the wall
I'll heed II can't get any worse
yeah yeah this is hardly the moat the
most inflammatory thing Joe and Mika
have said about Donald Trump - well
there's been this sort of often on
relationship between Trump in the
morning Joe people because remember when
the leaked audio caught Trump talking
with Mika and Joe during a break and it
looked like they were all very
buddy-buddy remember this what do you
have after this I make a speech
get in a plane make a speech working
well like a Bloomberg Oh of all the
polls out today were great one oh yeah
we're good well so so I'm being hit you
know they're spending seventy five
million dollars on negative ads and me
over the last two weeks right are they
catching on it oh no what do you think
are they catching on now delicious
they're spending a tremendous amount on
negative ads on me no you know what I
thought was the kind of WoW moment was
the guy you brought up on stage pointed
several times it's more plate it up
against Obama both guys the both outside
oh yes we played Obama first the young
guy then we scared the guys actually
know what you show this more room yeah
me almost as a legendary figure I like
no idea this morning when we basically
said today was we were completely wrong
about totally yeah I thought it I
thought I did really well in the debate
I didn't yes I read your question you
did not write oh my god but then after
being very buddy-buddy Joe Scarborough
just a couple of weeks ago actually said
that Trump didn't seem to understand why
he couldn't just new country so things
going in a different direction with
their relationship take a look several
months ago a foreign policy expert on
international level went to advise
Donald Trump and three times he asked
about the use of nuclear weapons three
times he asked at one point if we have
them why can't we use them that's one of
the reasons why he has he just doesn't
have foreign policy experts from Trump
asked three times three times in an hour
briefing why can't we use nuclear
weapons
with that be careful America and be
careful Republican leaders so general
Hayden the problem is blowing up I want
to ask uh so I get that there is some
tension here but I go back to the main
question if a presidential candidate is
threatening media people on social media
that is not someone that should be
President of the United States period no
further discussion is required if I'm
wrong let me know on Twitter at D Pakman
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed dot-com slash TDP s I don't
really like going into glasses stores
and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need you can try
five pairs and see what you like check
out the at home trial and support our
show by going to Warby Parker dot-com
slash TDP s it costs nothing